so let's start by the other fans in the
room okay you probably have noticed the
marae are getting bigger and bigger
there is a nice graph that Victor san
made last year which shows how these
models are just getting crazy bigger
it's exponentially increasing so now the
state of the art models there are over 1
billion parameters and they actually
fall of that because several models are
now like 10 billion parameters like T 5
and the Turing model for Microsoft and
you have a huge problem with these
models because they don't even fit on
one GPU and I'll even into GPU you need
like 4 to a GPU just to load this model
and to run them with a batch size of one
okay now why is it a problem well that's
a huge problem because if you check like
the current liter bottles for instance
the glue little bro that you can see
here you can see that the competition is
narrowing okay it's all about the same
teams now there's like Google Microsoft
Amazon buy your facebook or that's
pretty much it you see there is no
academics there okay because just two
models are too big the computational
requirements are too big so there's a
huge problem of diversity and also where
there's academia feats in commerce
recision lb okay another problem that
you've probably seen is the environment
of cost of finding smaller okay
they pay a lot of energy energy consumed
and generate carbon taxes and so we know
that training this model is not good for
the amounts what can we do and the last
problem was very well studied by for
specialized means that if it does go
bigger what do we expect we expect like
to see a phase transition at some point
or is it just like building bigger
scales to try to to reach the moon okay
now there is another option which is to
go the other way we know that since this
very nice paper of Anika I really like
the title optimal brain damage in 1989
we know that neural nets are over
parameterize they have too much weights
we can just prune them and they're like
the most reasons the most recent example
is the lottery ticket I put which say
that if you take a randomly initialized
model you can actually find a subset
inside of these models which already has
good good performances on your test
ask okay you don't even need to train
your model you can just take this big
model and find a subset do small
subnetworks inside of it that's already
nice for your task and we see that in
fact you model as well when you when you
find you model you can remove weights
you can select the waist and you keep
the performances so here you see this
example on NLP tasks where actually you
can remove like 90 percent of the
weights and keep the same performances
okay so we want to push in this
direction so here is a small promotion
we're doing competition that started
actually two days ago which is about
getting the more efficient models that
you can okay it's called sustained LP
it's a workshop but we will click a
collocated with yemen LP at the end of
the year
and the goal is to get this to the same
special as the current state-of-the-art
model like birthdays for instance and
just to try to be the most efficient
most energy efficient that you can okay
the competition is only only firms for
now because inference is actually one of
the the biggest part when you when you
look at the lifetime contribution of a
model like the lifetime computational
cost when these models they are like
deployed in application unlike thousand
of servers actually inference courses is
the biggest part of their lifetime
environment cost okay so if we can get
better on difference we like already a
long ways well goal of getting more
efficient models now how can you reduce
the size of the models okay so we start
by this let's go a bit into that there
are many them they're mostly like Sri
techniques that you can use the first
one is called distillation second one is
pruning and then there is conscious
action okay so distillation here is a
good example we made a model called
distilled Birds at the end of last year
which get like 95 performances of birds
model unglue and is like 40% smaller how
you do that when you take bird as a
teacher model which means you have a pre
trained bird and then you will train a
student model which will be smaller and
you train the student model to reproduce
the generalization capabilities of the
teacher okay so here is a good example
you see this sentence I think
is the beginning of beautiful and then
the model is asked to complete so Bert
is trained like that bursty strange who
predicts mass token so here you see the
top prediction of birds and you see they
all make sense okay you see daily life
future story all this top prediction
that bird things are possible they all
make sense
this is what we call generalization
model bird model learn to generalize
okay we are beyond your just a simple
training example in in this sentence and
what we do is that the students model
will be trying to generalize in the same
way as the teacher model so it will
learn inductive bias that the teacher
model has learned it's very easy we just
do a croissant robe it's called the
knowledge distillation and we do stew a
person from between the output of our
students and output of our teacher okay
when we train you can use temperature to
like emphasize the lower probability
that's very that's very common trick in
LP so now a lot of people have been
publishing in on distillation at the end
of last year you can see a couple of
paper like the state of the art
distillates with distillation models are
kind of very complex now tiny birds will
be the example where the student model
had to be as a smallest size of
Interstates and they try to make the
stern model also mimic to hidden states
of the of the teacher so you have down
downs you have a down projection from
the teacher to the student
they also user all of that augmentation
so it's kind of tricky to know exactly
what is the good what part of the good
performance of this this latest model
come from that segmentation what part
come from this station but definitely
people can get like very small models
with good performances using mix of
distillation and that segmentation
now let's move on to the second
technique you can use to reduce the size
of the mobile okay which is called
pruning
improving you directly work on your
teacher model and you actually remove
waste from this model to make it smaller
there are various way you can prove and
one simple way is actually to remove the
tension heads in your transformer it was
shown by to join two nice paper of last
year one by Alina Porter from Edinburgh
University
otherwise a pole Michel at CMU and they
show that you can actually remove a lot
of the heads of transformer model after
they've been trained and you can keep
very good performances so on the top you
see the results on translation you see
that you can actually remove a 90% of
the heads and keep a very good blue
score and at the bottom you see the
result on blue which is the general
language understanding match mark and
you see pretty much the same performance
so one way you can identify the heads
you should remove is by using what
michelle and polish also called the
skull the head importance call which is
actually their the grant of the loss we
forgot to there to the output of the
attention layer and if you if you remove
the the last important heads first you
can actually kill this very good
performance what is interesting is that
you see on the other slash graph here is
that you can actually if you remove some
heads that are less important for one
task here it's an Amanda lie you can
actually see that this this is quite
resilient to domain adaptation so here
in the middle I you have to part from
the data set you have what is called the
match data set on the mismatch that is
it and if you remove some hairs that are
not useful for one you can see that
actually it's kind of related well okay
the graph is not exactly linear but
there is some correlation with heads
that are not important on another domain
okay so which means that there are some
has actually not useful for anything at
least on MN RI okay that's interesting
because it means this is quite resilient
to the man adaptation now you can also
tie out here remove the weights when you
remove the weights it's actually more
fine-grained
because each each specific weights can
be removed but the problem is that you
will end up with a very sparse matrices
that are not so good for GPUs we'll talk
about that later but you can get also
very good performances here is a nice
paper from asset team with Jerry
whirlwind and G hang Wong and they did a
very nice paper that his awareness were
complete rain models as well
removing weights with a nice
[Music]
differentiable s0 pruning okay they use
like a are concrete distribution which
is basically the the Gumbel softmax
trick okay and the last part is actually
let your pruning in layer pruning this
is nice paper by hundred a fan of last
year at Facebook as well
they actually remove full layers of the
transformer so this is this is really a
lot okay you remove this this pool
player so the way you can actually do
that and have the model still behave
quite well is by training the models to
be resilient to that so during free
training you will randomly remove weight
remove layers sorry like a drop out okay
it's a structured approach you drop
layers and so the model learns to
actually behave well without some ways
it works well because this transformers
layer they are like a repetition of the
same module okay and you have this
residual connection this shortcut
connection which means that actually one
layer and the next one there are kind of
they are always connected with a
shortcut as well so when you remove a
layer it's actually less aggressive than
in some like fully connected models
without shorter connection so layer
pruning is very interesting as well and
you keep these dance matrices because
you remove full blocks of weights so why
am I talking about this problem of
sparsity well because all these models
will run them on GPUs and GPUs our GPUs
but CPUs and GPUs they are really
optimized for dense matrix
multiplication okay they have troubles
with sparsity and when you use this
space model on GPU on GPU or GPU they
are usually way slower it can be like
three to four times over to run so
they're smaller indeed but they also
lots a lot slower and it's also not
efficient so you're losing what you were
actually looking for which was energy
efficiency so they are values where you
can try to circumvent this one way is to
use what open area was promoting which
is block sparsity so instead of removing
all these weights single weights you
have to remove blocks of weights and
these blocks have the nice size that is
a adapted to your GPU or GPU kernel
which means that you keep dance metric
multiplication well you can remove
blocks but actually when you do like
strong sparsity it means you just keep
blocks actually okay you might reach it
just a few blocks as you can see here so
this helps you the another approach is
actually to make a full sparsity but
with patterns that you actually control
so you can keep advantages of optimized
CUDA kernel now the more you structure
is positive usually the less
performances you can get because you
actually constraining the model okay so
if you have like unstructured sparsity
usually we can keep the best
performances and metrics but you lose
the efficiency and the more you
structure the sparsity the better your
your energy efficiency is and using the
worst your performances so another
alternative is to actually switch chips
and try for instance the new IP you from
graph call which are chips that are
specifically designed for spaz models
okay they are made of a lot of small
module can process data independently
and have this smaller RAM associated to
them and they can actually process
sparse matrices very efficiently now the
last technique I want to talk about when
we talk about shriek shriek shrinking
model is quantization quantization is
also very interesting we know that using
float32
using full precision floats weights is
actually not the most optimal way we
know that these neural networks they
also work well without precision and
even quantized integrals so we can do
that from our transformers as well ok it
converts the flow just 432 the full
precision weights into integrates so we
really reduce a lot the size of our
model and we use dynamic consideration
for instance where you have a scaling
and zero point conversion
and this works very well there was a
nice work by Intel
I called Q Egbert and it's really
working well you can try it it's very
easy in Python and so cool as well it is
very easy to apply conservation and a
bit like layer pruning you can do
training aware cancellation so you kind
of tell your model is going to be
quantized at the end okay you actually
train it in a way that it's getting used
to be quantized and so you have better
performance scissors as well at the end
okay